ready to make his first start of the
season
at american family field yeah he beat
the cubs back at wrigley field on uh
you know earlier in the season five
innings one hit
peralta did pitch out of the pin here at
american family field to start the
season until his turn came around and he
sticks a fastball right on the edge
a strikeout to end the first is bryant
with an about face
two and three four eighty nine
seven big league starts for relief
appearances turned 26
on march 1st but let me ask you this how
does that change a pitcher's game plan
if at all knowing that their best hitter
is not in there christian yelich well
you got to feel fortunate you got two
guys that are missing out of the lineup
swinging a missed strike three nothing
fancy there ron also just reached back
and fired three fastballs all in about
the 94 mph neighborhood and down goes
lorenzo kane to ensue the count runner
at first peterson
and peralta deals a swing he had a miss
and that is right down the middle pretty
significant story early for freddie
peralta yes center cut i mean
right down the middle and baez with that
big uppercut swing you can see him
pulling that shoulder off and
coming up empty behind it
one two offering
peralta deals again he struck him out
swinging that time
on a check swing and bodhi couldn't hold
up
might be inclined to play a little hit
and run here but with that much swing
and miss that would be a high-risk play
and on the ground to third bryant
there's long there's two double play
and also using the defense
five four three that'll end beginning
chris bryant hits a drive deep left
center field it's got a chance
gone
to left center chris bryant a long home
run cubs lead one to nothing
left center field his third of the year
and the cubs have a one to nothing lead
he got that one yeah a little fastball
kind of angled away and up about beltai
out over the plate
and kb puts a good swing on this
fastball
and as you said drives it to left center
field long home run for kb
and the cubs take the lead that bull
landed i would say about 15 feet away
from where his very first big league
homer landed peralta has got peterson in
a one-two count signed a one-year deal
with the cubs with the promise that
he'll get a chance to play just about
every day not gonna be
in a platoon at least to start the year
called strike three
peterson upset
jeff nelson rings him up
and now it just throws the bat at a
breaking ball
oh it made him look bad freddie peralta
strikes out baez the last two pitches
not even close
that's to your point though rock he's
you can tell he's cranking it up early
to try to get to the fastball yeah no
kidding there it is slider look at this
there was a bad at it to try and get a
piece of it he taps his
chest saying freddie didn't mean it
peralta's got hayward
one and two and a swing at a miss he
struck him out a changeup from peralta
[Applause]
struck him out and that's five rows
alive
second time he's gotten bradley and the
second time it's that slider and bradley
just did
obviously not seeing it well he's
swinging right through
a couple
hittable breaking balls this one on the
outside part of the plate but up
and the o2
struck him out owlette gets kira that's
his sixth of the night five shutout
innings for the right-hander who's been
outstanding
ball three and strike two right-handed
batting
wilson contreras
and the pitch
it is strength free looking
that one a fastball that was knee high
and right down wisconsin avenue
harvey is sitting down low and away here
it is struck him out swinging
[Applause]
and the inning is over freddie peralta
just struck out his 10th
cub batter tonight
we've seen a lot of swings and misses on
pitches out of the strike zone by both
teams
that ball's hit sharply through for a
base hit
shift was on avayas
took the humble approach
[Applause]
this is mckinney six that bad as a pinch
hitter
he's two for five
so far on this young season
and he hits that one sharply in the
right base hit cranking it up narvaez
he'll hold there with hayward throwing a
wise move
the bases are loaded and mckinney how
good has he been he turned it into a
pinch hit specialist right now his third
hit already
contained away to get 0-1
[Applause]
out of
[Music]
they get the force there
and it stays one nothing cubs
that's such a smart play the reed
situation for baez he's a guy you're
always going to trust
one out in the inning the bases are
loaded
and left-hander andrew chafin is on to
pitch for chicago
craig council will counter with
right-handed batter luis urias
this is a swing moment in this game with
the brewers bullpen
as loaded as they are
you take a lead
after six innings
high percentage of win
in that scenario cubs know that
chaffing deals who is down the line that
is fair
into the corner it goes
one run is in two runs are in here comes
kane it's a free rbi double for luis
orios how good does that feel for arias
he is scuffled mightily at the plate
boy coming up big
first pitch
got a pitch in on them and just inside
that left field line
and luisa is wow
that's a big hit
and they're at the corners now for
jackie bradley
it's low and getting by contrast
here comes urias
and the brewers now lead
four to one
now chaff and ready again here it is
jackie bradley sends a rocket to right
center
around third and gonna score
avi garcia jackie bradley digging for
three here's the throw and he's in there
with a three-bagger driving in another
we've talked about jackie bradley ever
since he's been here
and we knew it had to happen at some
time
he's just too good a player to be shut
out the way he has been shut down
but you never heard anything from jackie
bradley jr
three and two hero right side base hit
another one will score
kesten
a two out two strike rbi single
six to one milwaukee that beat the shift
glenn right with it right off the end of
the bat
and another run in hey how about the
broker with runners in scoring position
this inning there's a 2-2
swing and a liner fair ball down the
line into the corner that's going to
score two bryant comes in peterson on
his heels javi into second and the cubs
within three it's 6-3
hugs not going quietly
putting up a fight here in the ninth
breaking ball
down but get two-able we say it all the
time with javi if you're going to get
the chase you got to throw it way down
way up way out very similar to
urias's double the ability to stay
through the zone stay long and get to
that breaking pitch and that means it's
hater time
josh hader
trying to nail down his first save of
the year
one-two pitch a swing it'll miss he
struck him out
josh hader closes the door and the
brewers win